you expect your partner to know
especially when it comes to sex
it's like well if you love me you should
know right
you know what i mean if you love me you
should be able to you should read my mom
yeah jada pinkett smith gets candid
about her sex life with will smith after
more than two decades of marriage it is
not your responsibility to make your
wife happy right
just like it's not my wife's
responsibility to make me happy
it's my responsibility to make me happy
and it's her responsibility to make her
happy and then we're going to come
together
and build on that happiness the 50 year
old actress opens up on the latest
episode of facebook watch's red table
talk telling her mom adrian banfeld
norris and guest gwyneth paltrow about
the difficulties of maintaining a good
sex life after all those years really at
the end of the day
it's
just not quitting you know of course
will and jada tied the knot in 1997 and
will celebrate their 24th anniversary
this coming new year's eve they share
two kids 20 year olds willow and 23 year
old jayden will is also dad to 28 year
old trey from a previous relationship
it's hard i know i'm i mean the thing
that will and i talk about a lot is the
journey i mean we started in this at a
very young age
you know 22 years old i think you expect
your partner to know especially when it
comes to sex
it's like well if you love me you should
know right
you know what i mean if you love me you
should be able to you should read my
mind yeah you know that's a huge that's
a huge pip
jada says she's grown out of that
mindset but it can still be
uncomfortable for her to express what
she wants
tell me
what you need tell me what you want and
on top of it i know that i have to be
accountable to do the same and do you i
really try yeah yeah it's uncomfortable
but
it's deeply healthy of course this all
echoes what will told et back in 2007
anything that i need
to make myself happy
i will present that to my wife that i
need that to be happy divorce is not an
option we gonna be together so we gonna
figure out how to be happy in fact he
doubled down on all that again in 2015
telling e.t that when it comes to their
marriage they put in the work you can't
expect it to be easy it's like
our marriage was the most difficult
grueling and excruciating thing that
we've ever
taken on in our lives and you know we're
just not quitters and by the same token
we're not apathetic so we're not going
to sit there and let it you know be
painful we're going to keep working and
if there is a is a secret i would say is
that
we
we we never went into
uh working on our relationship we only
ever worked on ourselves individually
and then presented ourselves to one
another better than we were previously
and just in case there was any confusion
on wednesday jada clarified her comments
about her sex life with will tweeting in
part quote will and i have never had an
issue in the bedroom thank you but back
to red table talk while discussing the
topic of sex with their kids jada and
gwyneth had very different experiences
willow started asking jada about sex at
the age of five and jada says she made
sure to preach respect and consideration
when the topic came up with jaden as for
gwyneth's kids 15 year old moses and 17
year old apple whom she shares with her
ex chris martin she said the topic first
came up when they were in sixth grade
and had sex ed at school the sixth grade
had the craziest sex ed
really
it was incredible full on
everything like they learned everything
i will never forget apple's face
when she came home and she told them
everything and when i say everything i
mean everything as for moses gwen says
he's not really interested in discussing
it with his mom he's like at a phase
where
you know we're extremely close and
he's also like
differentiating and he doesn't want me
to show a bra strap like let alone have
me ask him a question about a girl e.t
caught up with the oscar winner earlier
this month and she said that when it
comes to sex she tells her kids to trust
their gut i think the main thing and you
know that nobody ever tells you is like
you have to stay really close to your
own truth and you have to stay really in
integrity with that truth because
you know when you're in a relationship
and you're not being your full self
um you're sublimating things or you're
like white knuckling through something
it's actually i i think it's it can be
pretty damaging on
how you feel about yourself
i think
my generation we got a lot of messages
around sex that made us feel bad about
it i try to just be curious and you know
i mean teenagers are never going to want
to talk to their parents about sex ever
so i sort of follow their lead and
luckily in middle school they had a very
thorough sex education so the school
handled you know the kind of birds and
the bees
parts and then i'm there for any
questions or but the questions are
pretty minimal
you